unser top thema heute entlastet oder
schnellschuss kann sozialminister heil
das klima geld durchsetzen droht der
koalition neuer krach das top thema
jetzt im zdf morgenmagazin
also arbeitsminister heil will ein
soziales klima geld ab kommendem jahr an
diejenigen zahlen die als alleinstehende
weniger als 4000 euro brutto verdienen
als verheiratete weniger als 8000 euro
wird die genaue höhe des geldes ist noch
offen abgestimmt mit dem
koalitionspartner fdp ist der vorschlag
offenbar nicht viele fragen also gleich
an den zuständigen arbeitsminister
hubertus heil hier bei uns im studio
davor jetzt noch mal kurz worum es genau
geht
höhere energie- und lebensmittelpreise
und die inflation steigt auf ein
rekordhoch von 7,9 prozent im vergleich
zum vorjahr die finanzielle
mehrbelastung macht verbrauchern aktuell
schwer zu schaffen das entlastungspaket
der bundesregierung soll bürgerinnen und
bürgern finanziell unter die arme
greifen insgesamt 17 milliarden euro
wird die bundesregierung für neun euro
ticket energie pauschale und co ausgeben
hubertus heil ist das aber nicht genug
der arbeits und sozialminister plant
zusätzlich die einführung eines sozialen
klima geldes für untere und mittlere
einkommen menschen mit einem monatlichen
bruttoeinkommen von unter 4000 euro
sollen so von den steigenden energie und
lebensmittelpreisen
entlastet werden das klima geld solle
laut teil zum januar umgesetzt und
einmal jährlich ausgezahlt werden
innerhalb der koalition stößt das
soziale klima geld auf widerstand das
instrument aber von herrn heil das
müssen wir diskutieren das passt nicht
sehr bürokratisch ein neuer
umverteilungs topf und deshalb ist mein
ganz einfacher vorschlag lassen sie uns
im nächsten jahr eine reform der lohn
und einkommenssteuer machen um die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen zu
entlasten
klima geld oder steuerreform zwei
minister zwei vorschläge und der ampel
droht wohl neuer krach
und bei uns ist jetzt
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
schönen guten morgen schönen guten
morgen größe und hey warum haben sie
ihren vorschlag eigentlich nicht mit den
koalitionspartnern vorher abgestimmt
dann gäbe es jetzt nicht diesen streit
es geht ja darum dass wir erstmal
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
haben darüber haben sie vollen berichtet
das sagt in diesem jahr menschen
mitunter einen niedrigen einkommen er
hilft und ich will wenn preise höher
bleiben dass wir sehr sehr gezielt
menschen mit normalem einkommen geringen
einkommen helfen und das klima geld ist
teil des koalitionsvertrages ich habe
vorschlag gemacht wie man es aus
gestalteten darüber reden wir jetzt
warum haben sie es vorher nicht
abgestimmt ja ich habe eine ressort
verantwortung als arbeits und
sozialminister in mir ist wichtig dass
wir die menschen im blick haben das
jetzt besonders schwer haben nicht mal
ganz praktisch für menschen mit einem
hohen einkommen ist gestiegene preise
das ist ein stück butter jetzt 270 an
der kasse betrifft sehr ärgerlich aber
für andere menschen ist das wirklich ein
existenzielles problem und meine
verantwortung ist dass wir in diesen
schwierigen zeiten die gesellschaft
zusammenhalten deshalb diese vorschläge
gesellschaft zusammenhalten die
koalition sicherlich auch deshalb die
frage nach der abstimmung die sie nicht
beantworten wollen sie haben es schon
erwähnt ungefähr was geplant ist aber
können sie auch sagen wie hoch das klima
geld sein soll ich habe den vorschlag
gemacht dass das prinzip betrifft wir
haben in der letzten koalitionsrunde
vereinbart das entlastungspaket das
jetzt kommen 30 milliarden euro aber wir
müssen eine frage beantworten wenn die
preise höher bleiben langfristig weil
wir zum beispiel bei den energiepreisen
jetzt nicht nur durch putins krieg
erleben dass preise hoch sind so eine eg
hunger auf der welt wächst und
gleichzeitig für den ökologischen umbau
haben dann haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag eine
ausgleichsmechanismus verankert das ist
das klima geld und da die finanzen knapp
sind wir hinterher zu recht beschreibt
möchte ich dass wir das geld jetzt nicht
allgemein verstreuen sondern tatsächlich
gezielt auf die menschen konzentrieren
die normales einkommen haben aber dem
und arbeitnehmer rentnerinnen und
rentner studierende und auszubildende
zuhörer können sie noch nicht sagen kann
was sagen zum prinzip das prinzip ist
dass es um menschen geht die ein
bruttoeinkommen als alleinstehende haben
im monat von 4000 euro das ist ein
mittlerer einkommen in deutschland und
eben geringe und bei verheirateten wäre
es 8000 euro über die ausgestaltung wie
gesagt bin ich gern bereit zu reden und
damit sie sich keine sorgen machen diese
koalition hat noch andere fragen geklärt
das kriegen wir auch noch wir haben den
bundesfinanzminister gerade im ein
spieler gesehen der skeptisch ist und
gesagt hat er ist gespannt auf die
finanzierungsideen welche ideen haben
sie ja offensichtlich hat er
finanzierungsideen für eine breit
angelegte steuerreform also scheint
spielräume da zu sein ich sage aber die
finanzen sind knapp das weiß der
finanzminister das weiß auch ich weil
wir stark investieren müssen in bildung
forschung und infrastruktur in innere
und äußere sicherheit und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir nicht den eindruck als
staat erheben das für alle gleichzeitig
entlastungen geben können sondern wir
müssen den menschen helfen ist jetzt
besonders schwer haben ich denke an
alleinerziehende die sich beispielsweise
sorgen macht wie sie ihre nächste
heizkostenrechnung im nächsten jahr
zahlt für diese leute müssen wir als
staat ausgleichen sozialen ausgleich
organisieren und das ist unsere
gemeinsame fahrt aber diese leute würden
natürlich auch von einer steuerreform
für kleinere und mittlere einkommen
profitieren das schlägt die fdp vor was
spricht dagegen aus ihrer sicht naja ich
habe nichts dagegen dass wir über
steuern auch diskutieren werden ja
gerade den grundfreibetrag mit dem
entlastungspaket der wird wir haben die
eeg-umlage für alle abgeschafft und ihre
gezielte hilfen jetztzeit befristet auf
den weg gebracht aber wenn steuer
vorschläge auf den tisch kommen die am
ende des tages menschen wie mir mehr
entlastung geben in der tasche als einer
verkäuferin dann wäre das nicht gerecht
und auch nicht vernünftig angesichts
knapper finanzen und ich fühle mich
gestützt auch durch den
sachverständigenrat frau schnitzer eine
ökonomen wie die bundesregierung berät
rät uns dringend dazu dass wir nicht mit
der gießkanne das geld verkleckern
sondern dass wir gezielt den menschen
wirksam helfen und das leben ein
bisschen einfacher machen die ist jetzt
besonders schwer haben kritiker sagen
auch nicht nur die fdp es gebe probleme
mit der auszahlung das ganze wäre ein
großes bürokratiemonster also wie würden
sie das klima geld organisieren wollen
die einwände überzeugen mich nicht weil
wir haben in der koalition vereinbart
das kindergeld soll kommen der
finanzminister hat den auftrag und hat
das ja auch mit unterschrieben im
koalitionsausschuss die technischen
voraussetzungen dafür zu schaffen denn
am ende des tages geht es darum die
bürgerinnen und bürger von bürokratie
freizuhalten und das sollte uns doch
gelingen an dieser stelle es geht nicht
darum dass gründen antrag schreiben muss
oder ähnliches ich will noch mal sagen
das was ich vorschlage das klima geld
und auch das bürgergeld was ja auch teil
der veranstaltung ist dass es beide sind
koalitionsvertrag steuersenkung für sehr
wohlhabende menschen steht nicht im
koalitionsvertrag
das ist legitim dass wir jetzt in der
koalition über eine ausgestaltung reden
aber mir kommt es auf ergebnisse andere
ich möchte die menschen unterstützen
jetzt wie gesagt besonders zu leiden
haben die keine rücklagen haben oder nur
geringe und den müssen wir als staat
auch unter die arme greifen das leben
auch dauerhaft bezahlbar zu halten genau
diese menschen machen sich auch sorgen
um die inflation lassen sie uns zum
abschluss noch kurz darüber sprechen 7,9
prozent das ist der höchste wert seit
fast 50 jahren was kann und was wird die
bundesregierung tun um den menschen zu
helfen die jetzt von dieser inflation am
meisten betroffen sind wir haben schnell
gehandelt mit dem 30 milliarden paket um
jetzt erstmal auch gezielt zu helfen das
wird jetzt im sommer ankommen und wir
müssen antworten finden auf die frage
wenn die preise dauerhaft hoch bleiben
es kann sein dass die preise leicht
runter gehen auch in der entwicklung
aber es ist damit zu rechnen dass
energiepreise und damit auch
lebensmittelpreise auf längere sicht
nicht sinken werden da bis tarifpolitik
gefragt die löhne müssen angemessen
steigen die der mindestlohn wird ja
dieser woche beschlossen der wird auf 12
euro steigen aber wir müssen auch
gezielt entlassen aber ich sag noch mal
gezielt denn wir haben als stadt eine
verantwortung gegenüber den menschen die
jetzt wie gesagt mit normalem und mit
geringem einkommen sonst nicht über die
runden kommen und das arbeitsministerium
berkersheim vielen dank für das gespräch
herzlichen dank